it was the Champions League final here
at the stat de France last May that led
to so many concerns for Liverpool fans
as they were caught up in crushes and
they really feared for their safety
there were no serious injuries on the
night but UEFA commissioned an
investigation into just what went wrong
we're yet to see this full report we
believe it has been concluded but Sky
News has uncovered some of the key
findings from the review into that night
and it found that there were near misses
that nearly led to a disaster now there
were several factors involved on the
night that put Liverpool fans in danger
there were crowd control issues leading
from the train station to the stad de
France and a lot of the blame on that is
pinned on the French authorities the
French Football Federation who were part
of the organization and the French
police as well there's a lack of Plan B
that was discovered there were no
contingency plans to ensure that
security stewards could be redeployed
around the stadium to deal with crowd
management issues to prevent bottlenecks
that create a dangerous situations where
fans were being funneled into very
narrow areas and there was a lack of
significant crowd management issues this
of course was a Champions League final
selection of a host that was changed
very late on it was in February last
year that Paris was chosen when Saint
Petersburg was stripped of the hosting
due to the Russian invasion of Ukraine
and one of the issues found was the fact
there was no risk assessment for the
venue as we understand it and instead
they used a model from the French Cup
Final of a different match involving of
course domestic teams rather than in
this case Liverpool fans and Real Madrid
fans flying in to the match and amongst
the most significant issues evolved
around the stadium perimeter right at
the turnstiles where as Liverpool fans
were trying to get in we had local use
attempted to climb over the fences they
had no tickets and police deployed tear
gas and pepper spray which created
dangerous situations and fans at times
had the gates closed which meant they
were being pressed up against the fences
now what the report I believe will find
is that police were wrong to proactively
use tear gas and pepper spray in this
way and the fact he should not be
deployed as a means of crowd management
at football matches we'd seen it here in
the past particularly at Euro 2016 and
on the night there were concerns of
Liverpool fans that they were blamed for
being late at the stadium and that was
the reason why in fact the game was
delayed for 37 minutes what I believe
this review finds clearly is that these
issues were developing three hours
before kickoff well in advance of the
Champions League final beginning another
thing focused on on the night the French
Government tried to blame Liverpool fans
for trying to access the stadium without
tickets fate tickets were also alleged
what they this report I believe will
find is the fact that there was no Mass
dealing with fake tickets or attempts to
get in without any tickets at all and
certainly find that Liverpool fans were
not responsible in fact it discovers
that their issues actually with the
turnstile systems registering
potentially valid tickets and they might
well have appeared to be invalid or fake
tickets so it was a catalog of failings
it's believed from the French government
the French police the French local
football authorities and indeed UEFA the
reporters believe to find your way for
Bears primary responsibility but that's
apparently disputed by some members of
the panel and in fact also there are
clear issues discovered with the French
authorities and this Stadium we've had
no response from the french sports
Ministry the French Football Federation
UEFA also not commenting but this report
is apparently due to be published and of
course the attempt is to try to ensure
that there are no issues at Future
Champions League finals then they much
seeing this as a near Miss what could
have been a disaster one averted but
certainly concerns about just how
Champions League games are policed Rob
just just quickly because I mean it
sounds like the most important part of
this is uh is the conclusion as what was
at fault uh that nearly led to disasters
so that changes can be made going
forward to make sure nothing close to a
disasters have ever Revisited that said
that second part that you also mentioned
uh the way in which French authorities
blamed Liverpool fans in the immediate
aftermath is there expected to be in
this report any conclusions as to what
level of apology is owed to those fans
and by who specifically how high up that
goes within French authorities or UEFA
well there was an apology from UA for
last year after some of those initial
statements were found to be wrong and
indeed there is some criticism actually
of some of uefa's operations and events
division within this report about
potentially trying to deflect blame as
also a sense of local authorities as
well trying to deflect that
responsibility but in terms of the
actual blaming of Liverpool fans on the
night that was something that was spread
out by the French government by a
minister actually on social media and
certainly that's something that has been
focused on in this report where in fact
a Liverpool fans were found not to have
been the ones that followed it showed
the attempt to try to quickly assign
blame perhaps to focus Less on the role
of locals and locals who are trying to
clamor over the fences I was here on the
night and witnessed them and Liverpool
fans were actually shouts and get down
get down trying to prevent them causing
issues getting into this game and that
was one of the key things on the night
actually just how calm Liverpool fans
were in a distressing situation as well
as a pressurized situation they were
trying to get into one of the biggest
games of the season for them one of
course that they did lose and there was
a significant patience actually from
Liverpool fans and they're being denied
entry to the stadium as tear gas and
pepper spray was being deployed and
asthmatic fans were suffering disabled
fans were suffering and it's really
Shone a light here on French policing
and certainly that would be of interest
particularly with the Rugby World Cup
here late in the year the men's Rugby
Union World Cup and the Olympics here in
Paris in 2024 as well uh Rob house great
stuff thanks so much for bringing us
that Sky News exclusive